[ __ ] jetzt noch verwickelt
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem
weiteren video minecraft ware und nein
nicht minecraft warum ich hab mir
gedacht ich fahr ich heute mal ein
bisschen und laut einfach kein minecraft
war hoch der grund ist ein ganz anderer
ich gehe hier mal ganz kurz ihnen eine
runde weiter geben blog hunt ist nach
eigenen sieges blogger nicht trotzdem
hey den sieg weil blogger 90 ein
bisschen komisch an
wir spielen eine runde heidens tiger auf
mein plex ip steht in der beschreibung
wir brauchen noch einen spieler damit
das ganze losgeht aber da kann ja schon
ein bisschen reden und zwar weg kinos
und ich wir legen uns gestern abend so
nämlich gestern haben heute war es also
wenn ihr das video seht gestern mittag
denken okay superzahl 14 uhr warte ich
bin ich will übrigens leider seien wegen
gehe ich hier in der tiger team so und
ich hätte gerne den ein paket für paket
ist ganz gut damit kann ich wenn ich
dann ein blog bin kann ich einfach
aufeinander blog darauf die nicht auf
der erde oder in den mut dinge oder so
weil davon gibt es zu viele dass wir
dazu unmöglich für die heide einzufinden
aber ich kann halt einfach draufklicken
und dann verwandeln ich mich in den
block der nicht gerne haben möchte das
eigentlich ganz geil
und dann überlegt man dazu immer wenn
man dieses kit hat aber wir willkommen
bekommen wir wie wir kommen zu dem video
beziehungsweise zu dem thema was sie
ansprechen wollte wir legen und ja
wahrscheinlich nein wir denken uns kommt
wir drehen jeden kraftfahrer wer bin ich
denn überhaupt hier mal ja ich bin
crafting table jetzt laufe ich zum
beispiel hier einfach mal nach oben
stell mich gediegen hier rein
die haben auch genug zeit hier befreit
freilich doch woanders sind
dieses haus jetzt relativ nahe an dem
ding ich mich doch einfach mal in den
menschen ins kino
ich gehe mal hier rein jetzt bin ich so
ein scheiß kessel bin jetzt jede
renommiert wenig hier das geil ist ich
kann jetzt auch moment für sieben
sekunden kann ich jetzt mache ich
erstmal 30,2 sekunden
das ist nämlich kein machen ich kann
auch von fire ding machen
das sind so tipps die ich dann den
anderen leuten geben kann wo ich bin
dort das ist nicht irgendwie dass mir
das nichts bringt weil dann wäre es ja
dumm wenn ich einfach 100 zeigen könnte
wo ich bin bei den sieg sondern dass man
quasi extra punkte bekommen stellt euch
heute versteckt euch mit euren freunden
und die versteckt sich in einem schrank
und an der suche nur noch euch
beispielsweise und geklatscht einfach
zwei mal und bekommt dafür den zwei
süßigkeiten dafür dass er zweimal
geklatscht hat geklappt
ihr seid geklatscht die klatscher ist
kann man so alle zehn sekunden 15 -sieg
und alle fünf sekunden
und da die zurzeit noch alle da hinten
sind ja nicht irgendwer läuft irgendwie
aufs dach egal was ist los mit dem case
und ich denke uns gestern mittag ok 14
uhr superklasse zeit zum aufnehmen meint
raps hat sich das nicht gedacht meint
raps war einfach es war super ich hab's
angemacht richtig stark ich nehme die
folge aufgegeben alles super waren sogar
schöne sachen dabei also wir waren halt
erst zuhause kinos hat diamanten
gefunden
ich bin dann mal draußen gelaufen weil
der ist nur eine hülle der gruppe gar
nicht mehr nach draußen da dachte ich
mir okay gehe ich mal nach draußen und
zwar wollte die base von rewe und die
mieter suchen
guckt euch folge 16 an sage ich nur
jetzt schon mal wird witzig jedenfalls
laufe ich auch so rum kommt mir ein
bisschen die welt an boxen paar monster
war kurzzeitig auf zwei herzen alles
möglich eine richtig geile folge
eigentlich wollt ihr euch gerne
hochladen also ein richtiger unterschied
zu den anderen minecraft für alle sonst
immer nur einer höhle schönen kopf in
den sand gesteckt ich nachher sera chips
meine lieben freunde jetzt gefallen hat
dass seine bewertung da geht es ja gut
gute aufnahmen eine folge trat hängen
wir wollen da drei folgende aufnehmen
weil halt erste mal und so ihr wissen
naja jedenfalls wir schön wieder
aufgenommene ich realisiere so wo ist
meine dateien normalerweise speichert
raps die datei auf dem desktop
ich warte ein zwei sekunden an sich
sondern ich habe schaden durch diese
chance bekommen weil die heide haben
auch tnt ist hier denn alle angst das
ist ja entscheidende tipp ihr war ich
hoffe das hat der sohn geht doch durch
blöcke wahrscheinlich nur in so ein blog
hier
wir sind schon unternehme wir sind nicht
mehr haiders als hand halten
wir sind nicht weniger als das anders
dann kann man sich mal etwas cooles
fühlt
die datei ist immer noch auf meinem
desktop ich kann sie nicht mehr löschen
sie ist immer noch da drauf ich sehe
auch scheiße was wahr ist klar schon
wieder ein halb eins ist mitten in der
woche und ihr wollt die datei
abspeichern und es geht einfach nicht
meine damen und herren ist es geht
einfach nicht die datei speichert
irgendwie immer noch ab ich weiß nicht
ob das in zehn stunden zehn jahren bei
der nächste sonnenwende anders ist aber
die speichert halt immer noch ab ich
habe es dann probiert ich hab's dann in
der barocken bonds geschrieben habt dann
gefragt der jungs hat kann ich da machen
meiner datei speichern ihrer zeit ab und
diese datei wenn ich die dann in
irgendeinem programm rein ziehen möchte
also frühzeitig dann auch schon wieder
geschlossen natürlich und sie speichert
immer noch ich öffne premiere premiere
womit ich halt bearbeitet sie die
dateien in valad video file ich will die
datei öffnen windows media player ein
problem festgestellt schließen oder
wiedergabe hilfe nur so ein schwachsinn
nicht mehr fertig sehen los mit euch so
richtig behindert und dann schreibe ich
das eine war konnte der mann von broken
fans noch mit weitergeholfen der weiter
da nämlich laut ihr das programm wie es
erst einmal perplex nicht plötzlich war
ich guck mal ganz kurz nach jeder
milliarde richtigen namen sagt falls ihr
auch mal den fehler habt das programm
super suv als groß passt auf dass das
der basta passt auf dass dir der basta
die hässlichen suche leisten die ich mit
installiert damit konnte ich alles aus
einer kaputten datei wiederherstellen
kann da gar einer ja gut das heißt eben
auch mal ich lade mir programm runter
und ich will nur das programm haben und
nicht die fünf millionen leisten und
bing suchleiste nicht einmal im browser
drin habe mensch management muss man
wieder alle möglichen arten da weg
machen steht der empfohlene einstellung
ist ein tag nada im ok empfohlen lass
ich mal drinnen nach japan leisten wenn
ihr euch was runterladen macht immer
benutzerdefiniert weil das einzige was
benutzerdefinierte steht dahinter so
schwierig oder nur für admins oder so
was ne das als die wasser steht ist ein
haken bei einer reise muss einfach
ausmachen weil diese scheiß suchleiste
zu entfernt ob bei google chrome bei
meinem rechner 5 millionen jahre
das ist heftig jedenfalls ich dann
dieses programm runter geladen die datei
da reingezogen ist nix passiert
ich war der halbe stunde musste
eigentlich längst weg weil wir heute
englisch lernen wollten versender
lerngemeinschaft und abitur ihr wisst
ist wie wichtig bildung ist mir wichtig
nee nee also ich will da schon was wir
tun und an halbe stunde später das ding
100% vollgeladen ich denke ich sehe
sogar das bild von diesem video
und weil dann ein bisschen scheiße weil
ich habe es halt dann auch so vorladen
wir sind auf 5 15 uhr laden da irgendwie
gemacht oder so vier stunden später ich
war schon bei meinem englisch lernt
jetzt hier um nur 21 uhr ich guck da
drauf internetvideo fall dadurch auch so
los mit euch
die szene ist halt ein bisschen scheiße
gelaufen datei ist kaputt deswegen kommt
das jetzt so als ersatz video games zu
waro also ich hoffe mal das gefällt euch
das ich jetzt einfach mal ne runde hier
jetzt noch verrückt war das knapp halten
nur zweieinhalb erst am ende weil david
bakradse hier jetzt musik oder war knapp
am ende habe ich mir auf jeden fall
gedacht beiden ja wieder nix mehr habt
dann auch geschrieben jahr deutet wird
nichts das ist aber noch nicht in welche
video fall nach vier stunden hatten sie
einfach jahr machen erklärungs video als
bestens freunde kein streik bekomme ich
habe ja schon streik wegen der einen
folge die über 17 minuten dann war da
will ich jetzt keinen zweiten riskieren
allgemeinen strikes habe ich ja schon
mal als erklärt mit den regeln hat alles
eine wichtige richtigkeit in projekt
ohne regeln wer scheiße muss man sagen
ihnen war in hero wurden die oft nicht
eingehalten war da ein paar leute dabei
haben die auf jeden fall gut auf die
regeln achten was sie auch nur
befürworten kann ist das ganz klar das
ist ganz geil und das regeln auch
dementsprechend strikes bestraft werden
und streiks mit bahnen da werdet ihr
noch heute oder morgen ich weiß nicht
wer die auch ein paar sachen feststellen
dass ein paar leute schon wegen streiks
rausgeflogen sind ist aber noch nicht
online alles na ja die sache ist auf
jeden fall das ist der ersatz subaru ich
hoffe euch hat es trotzdem gefallen wenn
nicht lasten dislike da wenn's euch
trotzdem gefallen hat und ihr sagt hey
kam luca sowas garnicht mal passieren
dass einfach mal diese scheiß france
absturz vor was ca
vio wahrscheinlich es geht sogar direkt
wieder los ich werde aber zeit das team
nach inters team ja ich bin hinter
natürlich gibts ja unter steam herkommen
ein bisschen action reinigen damen und
herren
die sache ist einfach datei ist kaputt
ist
die war eine gute folge könnt ihr euch
auch biker aus angucken posten stehen
nicht in der beschreibung weil ich das
vergessen werde weil ich das jetzt erst
mal zehn minuten gesagt habe amerika
zehn minuten hier so drei minuten langes
video steht in der beschreibung nicht
wahrscheinlich nicht steht aber in
meiner kanal beschreibung also in einem
kanal k k
ich bin jetzt einfach mal der radar am
tag x ihm freude auch gemalt schießen so
von da hinten plötzlich wieder vor
seiner dann gehören da ist ja
wahrscheinlich vergraben auf was ein
hühnchen cooler typ
wenn sie jetzt holen wir noch ein paar
chips hier raus hat sich das ja irgendwo
drauf klickt wahrscheinlich von crafter
das blatt dabei ist kaputt was wir
gemacht haben war jetzt auch nicht so
dass man sich so denken müsste war oder
war so eine krasse dings ja aber es war
auf jeden fall eine witzige folge könnt
ihr euch bei kinos angucken wenn er
wirklich bock drauf habt und sonst würde
ich sagen freunde myspace.com den ich
meinen text und kombi steht in der
beschreibung check der ausgleich
gefallen lassen bewertung da wenn nicht
dann nicht
da will ich sagen ich wünsche euch einen
wunderschönen ersten mal das video jetzt
noch am abend hochgeladen was man heute
noch drei stunden gedauert hat
wahrscheinlich auch den erst mal
verpennt war das noch seinen sohn
hallo
[Musik]
ja ich bin noch echt zu scheiße einfach
für diese welt jetzt setzt er seine 1000
james gleich ein hatte er der richtige
james macht hallo kollege ja passen
gemerkt und der andere einfach mal zehn
jahre lichtjahre schneller als ich hallo
naja ich versteh lag katharina märkte
selbst war keine gute idee ich würde
sagen zum zehnten mal